le professeur antoine flahaut
épidémiologiste et directeur de
l'institut de santé globale à la faculté
de médecine de l'université de genève et
nous souhaitons vous entendre sur la
mise en oeuvre de la stratégie vaccinale
contre la copie de 19 lundi que cette
audition fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo retransmise en direct sur le site
du sénat et qui sera ensuite disponible
en vidéo à la demande
nous vous avions auditionnés lors de la
commission à 7 cette audition
comparé à certains de nos voisins en
particulier l'allemagne le déploiement
de la campagne vaccinale en france a
souffert de la lenteur il ya des
faiblesses déjà identifiés lors de la
première banque à propos des équipements
de protection faiblesse de la chaîne
logistique profession vous êtes exprimé
à plusieurs reprises dans les médias sur
le déploiement de cette stratégie et
nous sommes intéressés par l' approche
comparative vous pouvez avoir
depuis genève et puis en tant que
sénatrice du maine et loire salue le
choletais que vous êtes et rap et je
souhaite rappeler en effet l'importance
du nom flahaut dans toute la médecine de
la région merci professeur et je laisse
la parole
merci madame la présidente cher concert
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est un grand honneur que vous me
faites en m'invitant aujourd'hui et je
sais très heureux de devenir en effet
discuter avec vous de ces stratégies
vaccinales dans les différents pays
tout d'abord donc je crois que je vais
parler une dizaine de minutes mais vous
m'arrêtez évidemment à tout moment et
puis après je serai à votre entière
disposition pour vos questions et vos
commentaires tout d'abord je dirais
qu'il y à une deux stratégies vaccinales
possible en tant que tel il ya une
stratégie qui viserait limitée collectif
c'est à dire qui sera une stratégie
visant à barrer la progression de
l'épidémie
et puis il ya une stratégie qui
vise à protéger des personnes à risque
on en a l'habitude avec par exemple la
stratégie anti grippal qui donc orientée
sur des groupes à risque les personnes
âgées ou les personnes vulnérables
partout dans le monde
la deuxième stratégie a été choisi en
priorité
bien sûr avec l'espoir qu'elle va
contribuer à une immunité collective qui
un jour permettra de bloquer
définitivement la pandémie mais le
premier objectif est l'objectif
prioritaire dans tous les pays du monde
à ma connaissance et de viser la
protection des personnes à risque et les
personnes âgées
alors je pense pour ma part que c'est
évidemment là la bonne stratégie à
retenir parce que en lakovic 19 est une
maladie qui a un caractère exceptionnel
par le fait qu'elle est capable dans ces
épidémies dans ces vagues épidémiques
d'engorger les hôpitaux de submerger
parfois même le système de santé ou en
tout cas de risque et la submersion du
système de santé et donc de motiver des
modalités de réponse qui sont absolument
d'une lourdeur inouïe jamais connu dans
la société et dans la vie économique
également qui conduisent à des
confinement généralisée donc ça pour je
dirais aussi éviter ce type de mesures
exceptionnelles qui met à genoux nos
sociétés nos économies que cette
stratégie en dehors bien entendu de son
impact sanitaire attendu à tout ça ça ça
logique quand je dis que partout dans le
monde tout le monde a la même stratégie
je vais brossé un certain nombre de pays
puis taux plus tôt les pays européens
j'associerai israël parce qu'israël est
probablement le dirait le modèle le
champion dans le domaine pour le moment
dans dans la réponse vaccinale partout
en particulier le vaccin il est gratuit
dans tous les pays je vais prendre je
vais vite les cités pour être exhaustif
parce que deux avec ça n'est pas gratuit
dans tous les pays du monde mais en
autriche en belgique au danemark en
finlande en france en allemagne en
irlande en italie en israël en suisse et
au royaume uni
le vaccin est gratuit et il n'est pas
obligatoire
la gouvernance de la stratégie vaccinale
est partout une gouvernance qui se situe
au niveau des gouvernements est au
niveau le plus souvent fédéral quand les
états sont fédéraux de ces gouvernements
parfois c'est le cas de l'irlande une
task force adapté a été mise en oeuvre
et à peut-être attitude dans la
gouvernance plus proéminente que les
passeports tous les groupes techniques
que l'on peut voir dans les différents
pays y compris la france
le timing de cette de la stratégie
vaccinale a été donné dans toute
l'europe par l' agence européenne du
médicament dont je salue d'ailleurs et
je trouve que on a vu peut-être à 7
à cette occasion le caractère d'une
grande efficacité de cette agence
européenne
on connaît peut-être en connaissez
peut-être le fait qu'aujourd'hui tous
les médicaments en europe sont pas à
travers la les procédures de l'agencé
européenne du médicament et cela a
permis que tous les pays en europe au
même moment est eu accès à une
autorisation de mise sur le marché
contraignante d'ailleurs pour les pays
membres de l'union européenne
d'abord pour le vaccin de pfizer le 21
décembre
et puis pour moderna le 6 janvier le
vaccin de moderna le 6 janvier
on est encore dans la tente de
la motorisation de mise sur la marché du
vaccin d'astrazeneca la logistique
repose à peu près partout dans tous les
pays du monde sur dans tous les pays
européens cités pardon sur une
logistique impliquant des centres que
l'on appellera comme on voudra mais qui
sont des centres de vaccination d'autant
plus nécessaire que les vaccins riser
nécessite une chaîne du froid
particulièrement exigeante
concernant alors je le concernant les
priorités et après je reviendrai sur
différents points que je voudrais
aborder mais concernant les priorités
encore une fois partout dans les pays
que j'ai listé les priorités sont très
similaires c'est à dire concerne d'abord
les personnes âgées en alors avec des
façons de décliner les priorités qui
peut aller dans une grande granularité
un peu plus fine
on va dire les plus de 80 ans d'abord où
les plus de 75 ans d'abord roulé plus de
60 65 ans d'abord mais toujours est il
que les personnes âgées sont
prioritaires et les personnels de santé
ou les personnes et les personnels
également de deux en charge des des
institutions qu'on appelle l' epad en en
france mais aux maisons de retraite dans
d'autres pays ce qui parfois varie un
peu sur la marge c'est le fait que
d'autres groupes à risque où notre
groupe est essentielle comme des
pompiers ou les des policiers des forces
de police sont parfois aussi listé dans
l'est dans les catégories prioritaires
ce qui a été un petit peu discuté
notamment aux états unis par certains
experts c'était la priorisation des
maisons de retraite comme ça a été fait
en france ou encore une fois aux états
unis à la recommandation des cdc en aux
états unis certains experts ont dit que
l'on prenait un risque pour
la réputation des vaccins parce que par
coïncidence en vaccinant des personnes
extrêmement âgés en toute priorité
peut-être ces personnes âgées auraient
des incidents de santé ou des accidents
de santé qui seraient imputées imputée à
tort à la vaccination et que sam
discréditerait un vaccin en période de
de confiance limitée
c'est quelque chose qui est un peu
spécieux comme raisonnement qui est tout
à fait audible mais qu est un peu
spécieux parce que par exemple la
campagne de vaccination antigrippale
concerne toujours les maisons de
retraite ou les ehpad dans tous les pays
du monde développé en tout cas et ne
l'ont jamais entraîné ce type de d'un
discrédit sur la vaccination
cela dit c'était un alors il y avait
aussi un argument de deux d'immuno
sénescence c'est-à-dire que les
personnes âgées ont une moins bonne
réaction immunitaire que des personnes
plus jeunes et que donc ce groupe là ça
serait peut-être moins bien protégés
encore une fois ça ne s'avère pas vrai
dans les essais cliniques ça ne s'est
pas avéré vrai dans les essais cliniques
de ses vaccins et c'est pas du tout ce
que l'on entend aujourd'hui dans
l'expérience que l'on a sur ses vaccins
je voudrais aborder maintenant quelques
points le problème le défi majeur
on le sent bien c'est un défi
d'approvisionnement supply chain on
dirait en anglais et de logistique
la france attend 2 132 millions de doses
en 2021
mais en fait seulement 22 millions
seront livrés dans le meilleur des cas
avant juin 2021 les problèmes et 190
milles ont été à ce jour ma connaissance
administrés classant encore la france
plutôt dans le peloton de queue des pays
européens par rapport aux pourcentages
de taxation de ces de ses habitants là
les raisons de ce retard au démarrage
sont multiples sans doute mais j'en
donnerai j'en donnerai deux en tout cas
qui sont liées aux
à des traumatismes collectifs mais qui
ont probablement influencé aussi les
politiques et les cabinets c'est celui
de deux fiascos si l'on peut dire je
sais pas si c'est une bonne le bon terme
celui de l'hépatite b
c'est pas un fiasco c'était une très
bonne résolution que de vouloir vacciner
toute la france et notamment tous les
jeunes contre l'hépatite b et qui est le
pourvoyeur d'un cancer extrêmement grave
du foie et de débats ty chronique tout à
fait invalidante
mais les campagnes l'hépatite b ont été
suivies d'une pseudo épidémie de
sclérose en plaques qui n'a jamais été
retrouvé dans les autres pays du monde
d'ailleurs et qui n'a jamais pu être
démontré comme étant imputable au vaccin
de l'hépatite b
il se trouve que lorsque l'on vaccine
c'est un petit peu le cas de la
controverse initial dont je parlais pour
les ehpad
lorsque l'on vaccine en masse une
population qui fait quelques événements
de santé en particulier des scléroses en
plaques surviennent chez dans le segment
de la population des jeunes qui étaient
la cible de cette vaccination
eh bien on risquait en effet d'attribuer
à tort tout les sur venus même
coïncident talent de ces deux secteurs
aux en plaques après deux vaccins
d'hépatite b
toujours est il que ça a été un premier
traumatisme dans la société française
c'est le deuxième on le connaît bien
c'est celui de la vaccination h1n1 de
ces vaccinodromes qui eux se sont
révélés un fiasco parce qu'ils n'ont pas
été utilisés ça n'a pas été un fiasco en
soit l'organisation a répondu aux
attentes
le nombre de vaccins la supply chain a
été fourni nombre de vaccins ont été
fournis également dans un temps record
et nous les français ont boudé la
vaccination
je dois dire que tous les pays
on leur traumatisme ou presque les usa
ont un très grand traumatisme avec la
vaccination de la grippe en 1977 où il
ya eu une épidémie aussi de maladies là
est paré pour un vaccin qui avait été
fait en plein été à 100 tambour battant
dans la crainte d'une pandémie on a
oublié peut-être ce cet épisode mais les
américains ne l'ont pas oublié en tout
cas les dirigeants le royaume uni il ya
eu aussi une pseudo controverse sur
l'autisme qui surviendrait après la
vaccination contre la rougeole qui est
arrivé qu'au royaume-uni personne ne l'a
jamais observées d'une part ailleurs et
ce n'est pas quelque chose qui
aujourd'hui tient la route sur le plan
scientifique
toujours est il que ça laisse des traces
collective et ça laisse des traces chez
les gouvernants qui peuvent avoir des
peurs à vaincre lorsqu'ils doivent eux
mêmes faire face à ce type de deux défis
clés de mettre en place une stratégie
massive de vaccination
je pense aussi dans mes propos liminaire
que il faut surtout éviter de confondre
est de mélanger les anti vaccins c'est à
dire des personnes qui sont résolument
parfois dogmatiquement parfois
idéologiquement parfois pour d'autres
raisons contre la vaccination et les
gens qui ont pu exprimer
à l'occasion de la sortie d'un nouveau
vaccin pour une nouvelle maladie des
doutes ou des réticences des réserves
certains de nos collègues médecins ont
pu aussi attendre de voir sur pièce les
résultats publiés des essais cliniques
pour pouvoir avoir eux-mêmes une un avis
plus documentée toujours est il que les
réticences les doutes devraient à mon
avis se levait petit à petit avec
l'expérience que l'on va acquérir sur
ses vaccins
si cette expérience se révèle une
expérience tout à fait
je dirais paisible sereine et même
enthousiaste montrant l'efficacité très
grande d'un vaccin nouveau utilisant une
technologie nouvelle et qui semble-t-il
est associé à un nombre d'effets
indésirables extrêmement réduit
extrêmement limités et donc représente
sans doute d'ailleurs un tournant dans
la vaccinologie moder
je voudrais faire une proposition pour
regarder de l'avant plutôt trop regarder
de l'arrière cette proposition elle se
décline en deux points
le premier c'est de poursuivre la
stratégie qui est initié aujourd'hui
actuellement en france et en europe mais
on parle ici de la france c'est à dire
de vacciner les personnes âgées les
personnes à risque et les personnels de
santé en priorité comme on le fait
tambours battants ne plus possible le
plus rapidement possible le mieux
possible avec le plus de garanties
possibles est telle que la stratégie et
dessiner aujourd'hui et sans la changer
et sans la modifier
je propose comme deuxième point de
planifier dès à présent une opération du
type de celle que mon collègue et
confrère guy vallancien a exprimé sur
les ondes ya très longtemps de prendre
en compte le fait que les français
savent très bien organisé des élections
dans des bureaux de vote
le même jour aux mêmes heures à peu près
vous avez des dom des tomes et des
pommes qui faut que des heures peuvent
être différentes pour les uns ou pour
les autres mais pendant 10 heures le
dimanche
vous savez faire voter 38 millions de
français elle est convoquée où les
invités en tout cas à voter la vague qu
elles le veulent n'est pas plus elle
obligatoire que la vaccination
nous pourrions imaginer qu'au mois de
juin prochain
on organise deux tours pour la première
dose et pour la deuxième dose à peu près
dans les mêmes locaux
évidemment pas avec les mêmes personnels
ou les mêmes volontaires ou les mêmes
personnes réquisitionnées je ne sais pas
qui serait infirmières médecins
pharmaciens et qui pourrait peut-être
étudiants en médecine le formés pour
faire des injections intramusculaires et
qui pourrait
faire délivrer ces vaccins à tous les
français qui en seraient volontaires je
pense que ce type de deux propositions
rencontrerait une possibilité technique
d'approvisionnement si un laboratoire
vous avez des laboratoires en
particulier sanofi pasteur qui a le
savoir-faire pour je dirais package et
du vrac de vaccin vaccin niveau il
faudrait que ce soit un vaccin des
vaccins aujourd'hui ou très
prochainement mis sur le marché mais en
quatre mois ou 5 mois on devrait pouvoir
faire mettre en flacon l'équivalent de
je ne sais pas si c'est deux fois 40
millions de doses pour les français et
ainsi donner au français la possibilité
de se dire et bien 20 juin la page sera
en grande partie tourné
d'une part on aura vacciner toutes les
personnes à risque et âgés qui leur ont
voulu et d'autre part on aura proposé à
tous les français de pouvoir vraiment se
débarrasser de ce problème de se
débarrasser de ce risque et de pouvoir
partir en vacances tranquillement et
reprendre un cours le plus normale
possible pour ça pour pour une vie
sociale et économique le plus normalisé
possible voilà un petit peu ce que je
voulais vous dire et je suis à votre
entière disposition pour répondre à
toutes les questions que vous
souhaiteriez merci professeur nous avons
eu hier entendu le ministre olivier vers
moi pour ma part j'ai été un peu
inquiète du calendrier vaccinal tel
qu'il l'a donné
parce que vous parlez en effet de ces
vaccinations ciblées sur les personnes
plus à risque pour éviter des formes
graves de la maladie ça je partage mais
hier à une question il a répondu que
pour les plus de 75 ans en plus de 75
ans mais ce qui élimine quand même en
plus ceux qui sont en dessous et pourra
dire dans les 30 60 ou 75 ans et qui
pour certains attendent attendre
vraiment le vaccin
de pied ferme si je puis dire et nous a
dit bah j'espère qu'à pâques oui on aura
un peu terminé à vaccination n'est plus
de 3 75 ans a pas que moi je trouve ça
prénom donc ça veut dire que les règles
les autres ce sera et il restera ensuite
une une population encore nombreuses à
vacciner j'entends en effet ce que vous
dites sur la proposition de guy
vallancien d'envoyer un sms en ce sens
bon moi tu vas y à déjà les élections
régionales
et puis surtout mais l'idée d'une en
effet lui disait devant une organisation
du début de la vaccination disait mais
il ya des choses qu'on sait à organiser
pour faire venir en effet beaucoup de
personnes le même jour
donc ça en effet c'est quelque chose qui
pourrait être vu avec le ministère de
l'intérieur mais lorsque vous donnez
juin il semble que sanofi puisse que
vous avez cités sanofi sanofi et plus
sur un vaccin disponible en fin d'année
quels sont les éléments vous avez sur la
disponibilité par exemple du vaccin
sanofi puis après il ya de nombreuses
questions donc voilà oui sur sanofi vous
avez des éléments encore une fois juste
que je disais mais j'ai peut-être pas
été assez clair il ne s'agit pas du
vaccin sanofi
il s'agit de demander à sanofi de
prendre du vrac c'est à dire de la
substance active d'un vaccin existant
par exemple sur lui d'astrazeneca
car il n'y a pas véritablement de
problème majeur de stocks de ce type de
vaccin au jour d'aujourd'hui le problème
majeur pour la plupart des vins pour les
trois fabricants sont surtout de
l'embouteillage de la mise en flacon de
ces deux ans nombre suffisant et rapide
de ce type de bac 5 il faudrait des
accords à négocier entre par exemple je
donne l'exemple d'astrazeneca et de
sanofi je crois qu'il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui de contacts pris entre ces
deux laboratoires à ce sujet et que l'on
demande à sanofi de conditionner des
vaccins
d'un autre fabricant qui aujourd'hui est
sur le marché pendant une durée de trois
mois ou de quatre mois pour pouvoir
fournir au mois de juin mais deux fois
40 millions de doses dont vous avez
besoin et c'est cela dont je parle ce
n'est pas en effet d'attendre le vaccin
sanofi qui malheureusement ne se rend
pas à disposition en nombre suffisant
pour le mois de juin merci pour cette
clarification alors plusieurs questions
on va faire des plusieurs groupes de
jeunes guides shopping
oui merci madame la présidente de
monsieur le directeur tient d'abord à
vous remercier pour votre intervention
forte intéressante alors que dans
l'hexagone
seulement un peu plus de cent mille
personnes ont été vaccinées contre le
coc ville de 19 et vous l'avez
d'ailleurs évoqué plus de 10 % des
israéliens ont déjà reçu la première
injection de vaccin
dans ce pays la distribution est assurée
par l'armée il serait une des clef de
l'efficacité israélienne dans ce cadre
estimez vous que le recours à l'armée
française est à feu et à sang savoir
reconnus en matière de logistique par
les prêts douteux passer les lourdeurs
administratives du ministère de la santé
merci c'est un pur moment où je prends
plusieurs années on aura tendance à
poser trois questions vous ferez des
réponses groupe et d'en face à rades
oui merci
professeur en suisse dans le paix le
débat énergie sur la possibilité d'un
passeport vaccinale en france en avait
évoqué la possibilité de justement
utiliser cette occasion de mettre en
route le carnet électronique de
vaccination qu'est-ce qui les emmenait
dans les autres pays européens sur le
sur le à la fois le passeport vaccinale
le carnet électronique et l'utilisation
qu'on pourrait en faire par exemple pour
voyager et bien jean marie
vanlerenberghe ensuite le professeur
flahault pourra répondre oui monsieur le
professeur merci de vos propos qui
effectivement sont rassurants puis je
dirais ans en phase avec ce que nous
avons entendu hier par le ministre
monsieur les rangs ce partage moi aussi
votre idée votre suggestion que vous
avez repris du professeur avance hier
sur la planification et l'organisation
deux tours de vaccins j'espère
d'ailleurs que personne sera mort entre
les deux tours et et je crois que
c'est une excellente idée une initiative
mais se pose le problème et vous l'avez
dit de la ligue de l'approvisionnement
en vaccins et vous avez cité des
chiffres au départ qui vont un peu
étonné vous avez parlé que pour le mois
de juin
la france serait touché 22 millions de
vaccins or je regarde j'ai écouté hier
ce que disait le ministre
on aurait ce chiffre 21 exactement en
mars donc
et si je regarde un planning qui nous
est lui trouver dans un journal journal
du dimanche 30 pas de citer on serait à
environ 77 millions en juin
sans compter sanofi c'est à dire avec
astrazeneca est un peu de coeur vaquer
johnsen est-ce que vous avez vous des
statistiques plus précises sur la
fourniture des vaccins et en particulier
pour la france qui soit effectivement
clairement puis clairement peut-être
exprimé que je ne les fais merci
beaucoup merci vous pouvez commencer à
répondre ensuite on a une autre série de
christian d'accord merci madame la
présidente et merci pour pour vos
questions et pour vos commentaires me
prouver commenté sur l'armée et sur la
logistique
je crois en effet que le gouvernement
est dans une course contre la montre
qu'il faut gagner c'est à dire que là on
nous redoutons avec 7
ce nouveau variant britanniques mais
aussi le nouveau variant d'afrique du
sud que le virus puisse être plus
contagieux encore et puis se frayer un
chemin malgré le fait que une certaine
immunité collective commence à s'écrire
dans la population et commencer devrait
commencer à représenter un certain frein
sur l'épidémie de l'immunité peut être
complété et notamment la protection des
personnes à risque peut-être
complétée par la vaccination aujourd'hui
et si on arrive à vacciner rapidement le
plus rapidement possible alors on
évitera une mortalité évitable et on
évitera aussi nos risques de nouveau
confinement du pays donc c'est un enjeu
absolument crucial et toutes les forces
pourquoi pas les forces armées
pourraient pourraient être mobilisés
pour accélérer le processus et la
logistique je suis d'accord avec vous
que 200 milles à peu près à 1 190 mines
vaccin je crois au 12 janvier alors que
le pays on a sans doute reçu dans ses
congélateurs doit d'en avoir
probablement près d'un million de doses
c'est encore insuffisant et cela montre
que la montée en charge doit encore
progresser
donc tout ce qui est mobilisable est
bien venu pour vous dire nous avons eu
nous faisons face à peu près au même
défi un peu partout très
particulièrement dans le canton de
genève
notre situation par habitant est plus
proche de celle de l'espagne que celle
de la france dont elle est meilleure que
celle de la france par le canton de
genève
mais elle est inférieure à celle de
l'allemagne pour vous dire made man il
ya aussi des controverses
aujourd'hui concernant la chaîne du
froid les rupture de chaîne de froid et
c'est donc ces controverses
elles sont presque consubstantiel de la
gestion d'une telle crise
mais on peut sans doute faire mieux et
de toute façon on doit faire le plus
possible et le mieux possible parce que
il ya cette course contre la montre pour
la deuxième question concernant le
passeport vaccinale
le carnet de vaccination électronique
alors nous avons à genève en suisse
un carnet de vaccination électronique et
bien sûr le les données de la
vaccination sont reportées dans ce
carnet électronique et nous délivrons un
certificat à la fin de chacune des
vaccinations qui n'est pas un passeport
vaccinale véritablement ou au jour
d'aujourd'hui
moi je mets mon sentiment est que cela
pourrait faire l'objet d'une résolution
à l'assemblée mondiale de la santé
vous savez qui est l'organe de
gouvernance de l'organisation mondiale
de la santé qui se déroule
à genève au mois de mai d'habitude
c'était virtuel c'est l'année dernière
et il pourrait y avoir une résolution à
la demande des états membres les états
membres auront perrin européens peuvent
tout à fait refaire cette demande que la
vaccination glide soit l'objet d'une
mention dans le carnet de vaccinations
internationales car ça dépend du
règlement sanitaire international
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui est
fait qu'ils aient connu c'est un outil
qui existe et qu'il ne faut pas
nécessairement réinventer vous savez que
la fièvre jaune je crois même le pour
aller en guyane de la réglementation
sanitaire at heart le règlement
international impose la vaccination
contre la fièvre jaune est bien ou c'est
vrai aussi pour d'autres pays comme le
brésil par exemple eh bien vous avez
incarné international qui est magnifique
pourquoi cette importance parce que on
peut y avoir un marché noir où un trafic
de faux carnets de fosse de deux
fossiles un faux enregistrement de faux
certificats et je pense qu'il ne vaut
mieux pas laisser cela à l'initiative
des états sera compliqué pour les police
aux frontières de le vérifier il vaut
mieux que ce soit sur le plan de l'om
est ce que ce type de dispositif soit
réglé et puis concernant ce que vous
m'avez dit sur l'approvisionnement je
partage évidemment tout à fait votre
avis voilà vous avez des chiffres
différents des miens je dis pas du tout
les biens soient meilleurs que les vaut
tous plus à jour je fournirai adam
exerçant de maillots qui m'a contacté
pour l'organisation de cette de cette
audition la référence dans laquelle j'ai
pris mon chiffre qui vient d'une
communication qui est passé sur bfm tv
mais qui est sur internet et qui est un
tableau qui montre mois par mois
l'approvisionnement et la source de ce
document est indiqué comme
gouvernementale simplement elle est
datée peut-être qu'elle est plus
ancienne que la vôtre et donc vous
pourrez comparer cette source
avec la vôtre mais je vois là c'est une
source que j'ai puisé sur sur ce site
merci daniel chasseurs merci ça paraît
quand ils madame la présidente
merci monsieur le professeur donc je
suis professeur vous avez dit enfin ça
se passe en france c'est un des deux
pays donc les personnages et les
personnes à risque ont été vaccinées
avec le vaccin
kaiser mais de conservation difficile
puisqu'il faut qu'ils soient conservés à
moins 80 degrés et ma question c'est si
nous avions manar ii disponible le
vaccin astres année ceca eh bien vous
avez parlé d'une vaccination à deux
tours mais ne pensez vous pas que on
pourrait vacciner rapidement et très
fortement avec les médecins les
pharmaciens les infirmières comme la
grippe et en 20 à 30 jours on aurait
vacciner toute la population parce que
ce vaccin se conserve entrevue 2 et 8
degrés ce qui est complètement différent
bien rené paul savary
donnez votre avis sur le décalage de la
deuxième injection de 3 à 6 semaines
pour lequel nous n'avons pas eu les
garanties scientifiques avec le ministre
est ce qu'il ya eu des bases
scientifiques qui ont été analysées ou
est ce un simple report pour vacciner un
maximum de personne puisque j'ai vu un
article encore hier soir de savants
français dans ce domaine là qui dit
préconiser de respecter les trois
semaines
corinne imbert et ensuite le professeur
flahault quand les nimbes et remercie
même la présence merci professeur une
remarque tout d'abord avant ma question
on évoquait avec la question de ma
collègue joe c'est une idée tout à
l'heure la logistique
je pense je sais pas comment ça se passe
en suisse je pense qu'il faudrait pas
oublier en france un logistique qui
incombent aux grossistes répartiteurs
qui ont une mission de service public
kir deux fois par semaine officines et
qui sont capables d'assurer une
logistique deux fois par jour pardon oui
excusez moi docteur deux fois par jour
bien sûr
et qui sont qui sont des professionnels
de la logistique en termes de
médicaments dans la continuité de la
question posée par une et paul savary
parce qu'on voit bien qu'il ya un vent
de créativité qui souffle sur sur le
calendrier vaccinal rené paul évoqué le
décalage de la deuxième injection
certains même envisage une
interchangeabilité des vaccins entre
celui utilisé pour la première injection
et celui utilisé par la deuxième
injection interchangeabilité entre deux
vaccins arn messager ou même
interchangeabilité entre un vaccin avec
arn messagers pour la première injection
et avec saad et nos vies russe comme
celui d'astra zeneca que pensez-vous
j'allais dire de ces panachage envisagée
et surtout est-ce que ces usages hors
autorisation de mise sur le marché
oraux des conséquences collectif je vous
remercie sa soeur un beau d'accord alors
merci aussi pour cette deuxième volet de
questions dans l'eau vous avez raison de
dire que le vaccin files air est très
différent et beaucoup plus contraignant
que celui de modern how d'astrazeneca à
venir pour en termes de d'utilisation
notamment par les officines de ville ou
bien les médecins libéraux pour fiber il
n'en est pas question
c'est pas possible le conditionnement
qui demande une préparation puisque en
plus on ne peut pas utiliser le vaccin
même décongeler taken on doit le
reconstituer tout cela demande beaucoup
de temps par ailleurs l'utilisation des
doses de façon rapide
une fois que ça qu'on ait été décongelé
attend qu'elle en tire ambiante n'est
pas très compatible non plus avec les
oxydes de ville je dirais que pour
modern à être un petit peu mieux au sens
où il n'y a pas à reconstituer de
vaccins et qu'il peut en effet se
conserver au réfrigérateur pendant un
mois cela dit une fois qu'il est à
température ambiante pour l'utilisation
de là d'une dose il ya 10 doses a
délivré dans la dans la journée c'est
quelque chose également d' assez
contraignant possible mais contraignant
le vaccin d'astrazeneca apportera encore
une facilité supplémentaire pour que les
médecins ou les pharmaciens puissent le
délivrer donc je pense qu'il ya pas
d'objection du tout à mon avis à ce que
l'on puisse impliquer plus massivement
les médecins de ville dense est dans
cette logique là les des allemands ont
été réticents à cette idée là et ont
préféré une stratégie centralisée c'est
toujours intéressant d'écouter les
allemands dans cette stratégie en
particulier parce que c'est un pays
voisin proche et qui partagent une
culture très très voisine de celle de la
france en la matière mais leur raison
était que il ne voulait pas qu'il y est
une forme de passe droit qui pourrait
arriver plus facilement parce que la
pression exercée sur les médecins pour
pouvoir dispenser des doses seraient
plus élevés chez les médecins de ville
ayant moins accès aussi d'ailleurs à la
distribution via enfin à la sélection
via les bases de données de l'assurance
maladie en allemagne pour sélectionner
les personnalités les personnes à risque
par rapport aux personnes qui ne seront
pas dans les groupes prioritaires
donc il faut voir cela dit pas que les
médecins de ville seront plus sujet que
d'autres à ce type de détour mais ils
seront plus isolées et donc c'est moins
facile
possiblement d'avoir ces détours lorsqu
à une organisation plus solide plus plus
plus lourde aussi mais quelque part plus
protectrice donc on peut écouter ou pas
cet argument
je pense qu'une pendant une période de
grande pénurie on peut appeler ça comme
ça on n'a pas suffisamment de doses pour
toute la population
vraiment le respect des groupes à risque
et où des groupes prioritaires est
quelque chose de très important et il
faut être au moins certains de pouvoir
le garantir
si l'on passe par des canaux plus
décentralisée sur le décalage
oui le décalage de la deuxième injection
le médecin que je suis dans le domaine
des maladies transmissibles n'est pas
très perturbé par l'idée que la deuxième
dose soit administré un peu plus tard
que la première
je veux dire pour tous les vaccins c'est
ce qui se passe on a un calendrier
vaccinal qu'on essaye de tenir ce que
l'on ne veut pas ses administrés la
deuxième dose trop tôt on a besoin d'un
délai pour administrer la deuxième chose
c'est que la deuxième dose soit
l'istréen peu plus tard n'a jamais été
pour les autres vaccins
quand il ya un rappel quelque chose qui
est considéré comme annulant totalement
le le bénéfice de la 2de la
primovaccination donc en soi au départ
je dirais que je n'étais pas
particulièrement perturbé par cela
maintenant il s'agit d'un nouveau vaccin
il s'agit d'une nouvelle modalité
vaccinale et les essais ne repose que
sur ce que nous avons c'est à dire trois
semaines pour l'un et quatre semaines
pour l'autre alors respectez ce qui a
été d'abord mis dans notre nation
mission marche est respecté ce que le
fabricant a dit ça donne un certain
nombre de garanties pour le patient en
cas d'effets indésirables
on aura pas ou un fabricant ou des
autorités qui pourront se retrancher
derrière ben où nous avions autorisés
que ce protocole là et vous n'avez pas a
suivi ou votre médecin n'a pas suivi ce
protocole là donc je pense que pour le
moment c'est plutôt de bonne humeur sont
va dire de bonnes pratiques que
de respecter ce que l'autorisation de
mise sur le marché et le résumé
caractéristiques des caractéristiques du
produit préconise voilà le l'autre point
que j'allais dire peut-être sous forme
de boutade mais c'est que en france vous
n'en n'êtes pas là je pense lorsque vous
serez au taquet du stock écoulé des
vaccins alors vous pourrez vous poser
cette question
mais au jour d'aujourd'hui l'enjeu c'est
surtout délivré les deux qui sont
distribués mais c'est vrai que certains
pays commencent à voir cela et dans le
cadre de l'urgence
les britanniques ont pris cette décision
d'allonger d'une façon totalement
orthodoxe cette durée quant à l'intérêt
change habilité là je suis beaucoup plus
réservé à nouveau on ne sait pas jouer
aucun décès ne porte sur 7
interchangeabilité il était prévu que
année c'est peut-être cet essai est en
cours et lieu pour l'autre le matin arn
messagers et celui d'astrazeneca comme
deuxième dose en pensant même que
c'était peut-être pas simplement une
question opportuniste par une pénurie
des premiers vis-à-vis des secondes mais
aussi parce que ça pouvait être
peut-être une meilleure façon de
vacciner en termes d'efficacité on est
presque à 100% d'efficacité notamment on
doit friser les 100% d'efficacité en
matière de formes graves avec les
vaccins arn messagers et sans doute
d'ailleurs on doit pas être très loin
avec l'accent d'astrazeneca et donc
probablement 7
cet essai où cette interchangeabilité
avisé d'amélioration d'efficacité n'a
plus tellement sa pertinence aujourd'hui
en revanche en l'absence de données
d'essai clinique en l'absence de toute
expérience sur le sujet moi je
déconseillerais très fortement une
interchangeabilité sauvage non contrôlés
qui ne fait pas partie d'une étude
rigoureuse pour permettre de savoir
s'ils vont véritablement cette version
fiabilité n'est pas dommageable aux
patients par ailleurs je reprends aussi
mon argument de tout à l'heure en fin de
pour les doses c'est en termes de
responsabilité et d'imputation d'un
risque vaccinale tardif me retarder ou
rares on aura beaucoup de difficultés si
on a deux vaccins à savoir lequel est
temps qu aux tendances dans cette
histoire donc pour moi car je le dis
comment et puis sur les grossistes
répartiteurs je connais un petit peu
mais pas pas très bien en effet leur
rôle je sais pas en particulier s'ils
sont équipés de congélateurs à moins 70
degrés mais ça me parlait en effet dans
le cadre dans l'acheminement très
décentralisé allant dans toutes les
parties du territoire un des opérateurs
qui pourraient être tout à fait
essentiel dans la diffusion de rapides
pragmatiques dans les pharmacies
d'officine et vers les médecins de ville
ouvert les centres que j'appelais des
bureaux de vote avec guy vallancien de
dont on parlait tout à l'heure
merci en effet de rappeler ce que sont
les essais cliniques et la rigueur aussi
que l'on doit avoir par rapport à des
essais qui ont été pratiqués et de ne
pas on reprocha c'est quelquefois de pas
ne pas avoir donné toutes les garanties
et de s'asseoir dessus le moment venu
mais en revanche des collègues qui ont
été vaccinées ici on bien dire le on
aura dix pour la deuxième dose ce sera
dans six semaines jusqu'à un peu
surprenant et pourquoi abbas que c'est
c'est la règle ses six semaines bons
dans le contact
le ministre a dit que ce n'était pas le
cas donc on verra bien alors maintenant
vers une guillotin cathy apourceau poly
martin léveillé et jean sol
véronique bonjour bonjour monsieur le
directeur déjà merci pour votre exposé
la qualité pédagogique de
propos alors aujourd'hui je partage pas
mal de deux jours de mon point de vue
notamment sur le fait de dire que le
retard au démarrage des explications et
je pense que les explications que l'on
connaît sur l'hépatite b
j'ai des preuves de son on a des
problèmes de 101 véronique véronique
guillot talent nous avons des problèmes
de son jeu d'entreprendre
un pas quasi impensable nous avons
entendu le professeur ce qu'a dit madame
guillotin nom n'aurait pas du tout donc
on va passer à à cathy apourceau poly et
on verra pour gouverner guillotin se
reconnaît ensuite cathy apourceau poly
et merci monsieur le professeur alors on
essaye de s'adapter au fur et à mesure
parce qu'il ya déjà beaucoup de
questions qui ont été posées un mois
vous avez donné tout à l'heure un
chiffre de 232 millions donc de vaccins
jeu de doses de vaccins je ne sais pas à
quoi correspond ce chiffre je n'ai pas
bien bien compris apparemment je suis
pas la seule parce que laurence cohen
n'a pas compris non plus c'est pour ne
pas dire que j'étais là vous ne pas être
seul et puis ensuite moi j'ai une
question
l'institut pasteur à lille avance à
grands pas donc sur la découverte d'un
traitement qui éviterait donc de
développer des formes graves de la peau
vite 19 dans les prochains jours ils
vont demander donc aux autorités de
santé pour débuter les tests sur les
patients j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur
cette question je vous remercie
martin les voiliers merci madame la
présidente bien six professeurs pour vos
propos et ses doigts de ma caméra bloc
pour vous provoquer puis tous mes voeux
pour cette nouvelle année d'une petite
question sur la relation important et
urgent selon - pensez-vous que vous avez
pas être traumatisme tout à l'heure de
différents pays reconnaissant de la
france vit très bien expliqué est-ce que
vous pensez que l'idée du consentement
préalable est une bonne idée
par rapport à ce genre de traumatisme et
le fait que finalement un départ plus
lent dans le sentiment qu'on gère
l'important plutôt que l'urgent est ce
que c'était une bonne idée ou pas selon
vous pensez vous aussi que
l'accélération qui a actuellement va
suffire à rattraper le retard entre
guillemets qu'on pourrait avoir avec
d'autres pays
et puis enfin une question par rapport à
israël qui est partie tambour battant
sur la sur la
sur la vaccination et qui malgré un
confinement très très stricte il ya
encore quelques semaines à une reprise
de la pandémie exponentielle sinon à
tout moment la possibilité d'avoir une
humilité en fonction d'un développement
rapide du vaccin merci beaucoup
très bien pour terminer chance seul oui
madame la présidente monsieur le
professeur mes chers collègues merci de
me donner la parole les variants anglais
et sud-africains circulent aujourd'hui
dans notre dans notre pays
une vingtaine a priori de personnes
seraient aujourd'hui repérer et donc
toucher ou et vous nous dire comment
s'organise le suivi le dépistage de ces
patients et pouvez vous nous dire si les
vaccins
ils sont aujourd'hui utilisés auront un
impact sur ces variants qui qui
s'annonce particulièrement vrai en tout
cas virulent je vous remercie bien vous
pourrez commencer à répondre et en
souhaitant en essayant d'avoir et reste
3 3 intervenant ensuite présidente alors
pour les 232 millions de doses je répète
un je vous transmettrai le document
source où j'ai pris ces ces données et
je ne garantis pas du tout qu'elle soit
meilleure que celle que vous pouvez
disposer ce sont des sources ce
semble-t-il gouvernemental pour la sécu
pasteur de lille et le repositionnement
de leurs nouveaux traitements
mais je pense qu'ils ont fait exactement
ce qu'il fallait faire
je pense en particulier à cette une
controverse un peu pénible que la france
a connu concernant la chloroquine &
lybrand cycle rockin elle aurait pu être
elle aurait pu être totalement éviter
pas là proches qu'à adopter l'institut
pasteur c'est à dire une approche très
secrète
la transparence c'est très bien mais
mais pas lorsque elle le vend des
arguments qui ne sont pas encore
validées par les essais cliniques
or ce qu'a voulu
le massif du pasteur de lille c'est ne
pas communiquer trop rapidement le nom
de la molécule que personne ne connaît à
ma connaissance sûr qu'ils sont en train
de vouloir expérimenter tester leur
positionnement d'un médicament existant
c'est une des meilleures stratégies
possibles si elle montre une efficacité
parce que on aura plus court circuiter
toutes les phases préalables
développement de médicaments on n'a pas
besoin
repositionné un médicament qui existe
déjà sur le marché de refaire des essais
chez l'animal puisque les médicaments et
déjà donné chez l'homme on n'a pas
besoin non plus de faire les essais de
phase 1 et 2 ce qu'ils sont de
biodisponibilité de du médicament de la
molécule pharmacie tic puisque ça a déjà
été fait lorsque l'on a positionné ses
médicaments dans leurs indications
donc on a juste à repositionner par un
essai de phase iii c'est à dire un essai
randomisée contre placebo pour vérifier
que le médicament a une efficacité
clinique contre la copie de 19
si c'est le cas ça peut changer beaucoup
la donne puisque sur des formes sévères
si un médicament existait et permettait
de ne pas mourir de la copie 19 d'avoir
des séjours en soins intensifs
raccourcis ou voir même des séjours
hospitaliers raccourcis ce serait
évidemment une très très bonne nouvelle
alors là si pasteur de lille n'a pas
fait le court circuit de communiquer
avant l'heure la promesse que pouvait
tenir le 7 molécules candidates et n'en
a fait qu'un médicament qui devait être
d'abord et avant tout validé pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir devenir un
médicament dont l'extension de la mêmes
dirais que 8,19 voilà à ce jour bien je
crois qu'il faut qu'ils démarrent leurs
essais et je leur souhaite vraiment une
bonne chance pour qu'il puisse le
conduire dans les meilleures conditions
possibles mais je trouve que l' approche
est tout à fait louable
concernant le consentement préalable
je voudrais réaffirmer une chose il n'y
a pas d'actes médicaux
sans un consentement préalable peut-être
à pas la vaccination obligatoire
il n'y a pas de possibilité ou je sais
pas où le contrôle de l'alcoolémie lors
d'un contrôle de routine
mais en dehors de ces cas prévus par la
loi
très particulier il n'y a pas d'acte
médicale sans consentement préalable
en revanche il n'y a pas de consentement
écrit pour la plupart des actes médicaux
je crois que quelques actes chirurgicaux
font l'objet d'un consentement écrit
préalable mais tous les vaccins qui sont
régulièrement mis sur le marché ne
demande pas de consentement écrit je
crois qu'il ya eu un tout petit peu de
confusion dans les circulaires officiel
gouvernemental au départ et que
rapidement la notion de consentement
écrit a disparu mais c'est vrai que il
n'avait pas eu lieu
il n'ya pas de dieu pour ce vaccin qui
est mis sur le marché d'une façon
normale et il n'y a pas eu de procédure
d'urgence à l'agencé européenne du
médicament pour la vie sur le marché des
vaccins de pfizer et de moderne à la
différence du royaume uni ou les états
unis qui ont adopté une procédure
d'urgence
là ce n'est pas le cas on n'est pas non
plus dans le cadre d'un essai
thérapeutique n'ya pas lieu d'avoir un
consentement écrit il n'y a pas lieu de
demander un consentement différent de
celui que l'on demande pour tout acte
médical concernant le départ lent ou
encore une fois c'est quelque chose que
dans pleines fêtes de fin d'année etc
que l'on peut tout à fait qu'on se voit
un je suis pas moi-même aux commandes ni
de 2 min à un échelon français ni un
échelon suisse et donc je me permettrai
pas là dessus de faire de commentaire
qui serait inappropriée sur le fait que
l'on puisse rattraper le retard
j'en suis intimement persuadé je pense
que la france est en train de rattraper
le retard a décidé une stratégie qui est
basée sur 600 centres répartis sur le
territoire
et je crois qu'en effet c'est la façon
qu'il faut faire il faut qu'on soit
demandant une autre controverse puisque
on aime bien dans notre pays des
controverses et que l'on soit dans cette
controverse de la pénurie
aujourd'hui on n'est pas encore dans la
controverse de la pénurie de la double
de la dose décalé etc
j'ai hâte qu'on arrive dans cette
controverse pour que enfin cela si nikon
a complètement rattraper le retard et
qu'il n'ya plus de stocks disponibles de
ces vaccins on doit être en manque de
vaccins en permanence dans cette course
contre la montre pour sauver le plus de
personnes possible de des risques de
l'accession après vous me demandiez est
ce que en prenant la très bonne image
d'israël est ce qu'israël qui a déjà
réussi à un matinée plus de 60 % de ces
personnes âgées d'une façon extrêmement
dynamique et presque je dirais agressive
je mettrais un bémol
malheureusement israël n'a pas décidé de
vacciner les populations palestiniennes
et je pense que c'est dommage je pense
qu'elle aurait pu ou elle pourrait
encore d'ailleurs montré son savoir
faire mais aussi sa capacité humanitaire
je sais qu'il ya des associations juif
international qui ont appelé à la
vaccination des palestine mais en dehors
de cela
israël table sur avant la fin du mois de
mars la possibilité de ne plus avoir de
d'urgence sanitaire lié à la coved 19
c'est à dire de ne plus avoir
d'engorgement de ces hôpitaux de ne plus
avoir de lits de réanimation peu sur
occupés par les patients du coc vide
parce qu'elle aura réussi à vacciner et
à protéger la population la plus à
risque
ce sera sans doute sa démonstration la
plus emblématique que nous aurons à
notre disposition dans quelques mois
quelques semaines presque 1 puisque la
stratégie vaccinale israélienne a été
d'une très grande efficacité et qui nous
montrera on qui nous convaincre à voir
qui convaincra les personnes qui ont
encore des doutes ou des questionnements
sur ce vaccin pl de son utilité en tout
cas pour prévenir l'engorgement des
hôpitaux et le risque de confinement
aujourd'hui israël dans une situation
qui est boisé
ni de celle de l'irlande j'allais dire
de celle du royaume uni mais le
royaume-uni est en train de décrocher
sur sa courbe exponentielle épidémique
ce qui est une bonne nouvelle mais
israël est en effet sur une courbe
ascendante encore plus forte que celle
que connaît la france en ce moment qui
est forte pour temps et qui est dure
depuis plus longtemps en israël et donc
qui préoccupe beaucoup les autorités
israéliennes qui risquent en effet
d'avoir à prendre des mesures très
fortes
concomitamment à cette à cette campagne
vaccinale
quant aux variants ces variants sud
africain et du royaume uni
alors le suivi et le dépistage
il est clair que l'europe continentale
pas simplement la france ne fait pas
assez de séquençage les séquençages des
sous ça demande des plateformes ce à un
coût assez élevé et ça doit être fait
d'une façon très rigoureuse sur le plan
méthodologique pas simplement sur le
plan du séquençage lui-même mais aussi
sur le plan de l'échantillonnage des
personnes qui sont séquencé il faut
qu'ils signé d'un pourcentage de toutes
les paires positivité du territoire qui
chaque jour soit séquencé et ce
pourcentage peut être faible ça peut
être un pour cent des souches ne sait
mais il faut que ce soit fait d'une
façon échantillonnés pour qu'on puisse
dire est exactement quel est le
pourcentage
aujourd'hui deux souches de telle ou
telle va rien il faut qu'on puisse
retracer ce qu'on appelle
l'épidémiologie moléculaire en en
faisant cette étude systématique
les australiens sont probablement les
chefs de file du séquençage dans le
monde et ont réussi vers véritablement à
tracer des épidémies a tracé des supers
propagation des clusters massif l'hiver
dernier enfin au mois d'août ne pour eux
lorsqu'il ya eu cette très grosse
épidémie dans la région de melbourne et
le royaume uni comme l'afrique du sud
qui sont deux pays qui séquence beaucoup
ont été les premiers à découvrir à
repérer et à tracer des devarient
rien ne dit que nous n'avons pas
d'autres variant qui circulent et qui
ont aussi des potentiels qui serait
intéressant de tracé de près est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on est capable de les
suivre sans faire de séquençage je
dirais que par chance
oui parce que la paix c'est une des pcr
en tout cas les pcr vous savez c'est des
sondes c'est pas du séquençage de tout
le génome cd sont d'une toute petite
partie du génome mais qui est
suffisamment spécifique pour qu'on
puisse dire que c'est une infection par
le corona virus et bien on met trois
sondes dans une pcr du génome est bien
une des trois sondes ne répond pas parce
que elle est affectée par les mutations
du variant anglais et donc lorsque l'on
a des pcr positive avec deux sondes sur
trois on a une très forte suspicion
aujourd'hui qu'il s'agit d'un variant
anglais qui circule à ce moment là il
faut faire le séquençage de la souche
pour en avoir la certitude
mais donc on peut par ce biais là parce
qu'à peu près ne cessa correspond pas à
toutes les pcr du marché mais à peu près
10% des pcr du marché européen sont
concernés et donc on peut avoir
grâce à cela une forme d'échantillonnage
de ces de ces données là encore faut-il
qu'on sache évidemment mais combien ont
été concernés sur le vaccin
on a eu une bonne nouvelle de la semaine
dernière avec le vaccin de pfizer le
faillitaire a montré qu'ils étaient
efficaces contre le nouveau variant
parce que les anticorps neutralisants
que la réponse immunitaire suscitée par
ce vaccin produit chez l'homme sont
neutralisant contre ce nouveau variant
très bonne nouvelle parce qu'on peut
probablement père l'hypothèse forte que
le modern a va être aussi concernés par
cette même nouvelle qui est en cours
d'étude peut être les mêmes ou tombée
aujourd'hui ou étendra cette semaine
quant au vaccin d'astrazeneca je crois
que toutes les études sont encore en
cours et qu'elle devrait aussi tombé
mais on a plutôt aujourd'hui confiance
que ces vaccins vont être efficace très
bien donc il reste alors vernet
guillotin est gouvernée guillotin peut
se reconnecter parce que vous m'entendez
oui
c'est un grand moment de solitude
bonjour bonjour de ce flux direct ça
vient je voulais vous remercier pour la
la qualité de vos propos et la qualité
pédagogique notamment des explications
quelques quelques remarques et une de
question donc gg
nous avons eu hier une occasion
d'interroger olivier ferrand et
effectivement il ya deux sujets que vous
avez également quand vous avez que vous
avez également évoqué c'était un sur les
publics prioritaires
la question est est ce qu'il n'est pas
urgent aujourd'hui d'intégrer dans les
publics prioritaires non pas uniquement
des patients âgés mais les patients plus
jeunes qui souffrent de pathologies
graves
les immunodéprimés les transplanter on a
eu pas mal de remonter des services des
services hospitaliers des patients qui
sont aujourd'hui dans la vie active et
qui ont des fragilités qu'il faudrait à
priori intégrer rapidement mais je pense
que c'est ce que de ce que j'ai compris
en bonne voie je partage complètement
votre votre l'idée de dire qu'on a eu un
démarrage lent poussif moi je les
appelais avec effectivement des
traumatismes que la france a connu mais
que à mon sens on est quand même sur une
voie aujourd'hui d'accélération et enfin
en tout cas moi j'y vois j voie de
l'optimisme en termes de vaccination
j'ai également peu d'action du
séquençage et bim est en partie d'y
répondre mais mais peut-être pas
complètement donc le le séquençage on
voit bien l'intérêt du séquençage pour
déterminer les souches mutantes qui sont
aujourd'hui nous avons de la chance d'un
des souches qui sont réactives aux
vaccins c'est à dire ça perturbe pas la
vaccination est ce que ce séquençage là
est prévu et est ce que la recherche est
prévue au cas où un train une souche
aujourd'hui mutants ce ne serait plus en
adéquation avec les vaccins qui nous
sont proposés donc ça et mes deux choses
c'est un il faut se dire qu'il faut
vraiment accélérer la vaccination parce
que plus on aura vacciner peut-être ne
se sera et deuxièmement qu'est ce qui se
passe ou est-ce que des pistes de
recherche sont déjà en cours
en cas d'arrivée de virus mutant est ce
qu'il ya des prospectives ou des choses
comme ça et enfin
continental idées des deux journées de
vaccination électorales qui sont qui
pourrait être émise l'idée très bonne
parce que ça donne n'a effectivement un
éclairage important et une visibilité
bon après pratiquement est-ce que c'est
pratiquement possible vous avez parlé
d'acheminement moi je parlerais plutôt
de d'effecteur quoi ce qu'on ait une
ronde dans chaque commune des médecins
des infirmiers en nombre pour pouvoir
vacciner le même jour la population je
doute un peu mais ça remet un peu en
perspective ce que daniel chassaing
disait c'est à dire pourquoi pas sur ce
même modèle peut être élargir la période
en dit long sur un mois et s'appuyer
effectivement sur les médecins
généralistes et les infirmières et les
pharmaciens de ville sur une période
fixe avec un peu près le même état
d'esprit quoi parce que bon les deux
journées moi je doute un peu mais en
tout cas lisez l'idée me paraît
intéressante
et puis note espérons qu'on puisse avoir
effectivement une note d'optimisme dans
l'accélération de cette vaccination
voilà un petit peu les questions et les
remarques que j'avais à faire
merci veronica niklas même année que
jacques mais toujours là en visio année
jacmel jour là toujours là
merci monsieur le professeur ma question
en fait jean sol mais n'a soufflé donc
j'ai bien eu la réponse sur la mutation
des variantes et ce virus par contre
j'aurai une autre question vous posez
vous avez dit qu'on avait pratiquement
100% en d'efficacité par rapport aux
vaccins qui sont déjà pratiqué est-ce
qu'on a assez de recul pour connaître la
durée de protection des vaccins est ce
que on envisage dès maintenant de faire
des rappels annuel ou des vaccins
annuels comme on le fait pour la grippe
même question
rapport aux malades ceux qui ont été
malades et ce quand c'est dire quelle
est la durée de protection des anticorps
qui sont fabriqués et troisième question
on parle beaucoup orient c'est que pour
les enfants
il ya 11 max 1 qui sont rendus
obligatoires qu'est ce qui nous empêche
finalement une fois on aura suffisamment
de recul sur les effets secondaires
éventuels du vaccin de rendre ce vaccin
obligatoire du les conséquences quand
même aussi bien et je vous ai perdu lui
que sanitaires et sociaux de sept ans
d'émission voilà merci
et pour terminer mon mandat main
poumirol de bouquet final
non merci la reprise donc vers 6 heures
mais l'inconvénient de par ses organes
ici que des réponses soient était déjà
quasiment apportez moi je voudrais
revenir quand même sur ce qui me
semblait très l'essentiel c'est le
nombre de doses dont elle dispose et je
comprends tout à fait la logique d'un
avec ce vaccin
compte tenu des conditions particulières
est extrêmement difficile de le
conserver d'avoir une une organisation
je dirais semblant nationale qui qui
permettent de démarrer
je suis pas hostile d'ailleurs à l'idée
que l'armée sont et c'est ça qui est
extrêmement compétentes puisse
éventuellement nous aider ceci étant je
crois qu'il faut faire confiance aussi à
nos collectivités territoriales et on
nous ayons encore l'homme d'histoire une
réunion avec comme je le préfet sur
sûrement département et j'ai prêché
demandé à ce qu'on organise un centre
qu'ovide pour 5e timide habitants et non
au niveau du département on en pose un
problème 5000 parce qu'on a la
logistique qui nous permet de le faire
pour être là aussi le plus près possible
comme toujours des patients mais cessons
de covin finalement vont devrait avoir
j'allais dire une durée de vie limitée
limité parce que le jour où enfin on
aura plus que le non seulement le faire
mais aussi le mot dernier d'astrazeneca
pourquoi ne pas s'appuyer et on a
travaillé avec l'ordre des médecins
pourquoi
pas s'appuyer tout simplement comme on
le fait pour la vaccination antigrippale
sur les médecins généralistes de ville
sur les infirmiers sur les pharmaciens
et on est capable pour la vaccination
antigrippale de faire en quatre cinq six
semaines l'ensemble la population qui a
besoin de se vacciner
je crois que une fois qu'on ne sera plus
dépendants parce qu'aujourd'hui on est
vraiment dépendant du spyder une fois
qu'on sera plus dépendante du fader on
pourrait avoir une organisation très
simple classique basé sur nos
professionnels de santé qui sont prêts
qu'ils sont prêts à répondre d'autant
plus que j'allais dire on a beaucoup
parlé de la confiance ou plutôt de la
défiance de nos concitoyens envers la
vaccination chiffres au départ qui était
extrêmement notre bas de long pour l'
envie de se faire vacciner
je crois que quand tu y seras leur
médecin traitant
leur généraliste les vieilles amies qui
ne connaissent bien qu'il va venir leur
faire le accès où ils vont aller voir
pour faire leurs vaccins au cabinet 8,15
problème de confiance sera complètement
différent donc je crois que il faut nous
faire confiance sur le plan de
l'organisation descente kovy avec les
collectivités territoriales dans
l'immédiat pour les deux mois qui
viennent
mais je crois que ensuite on peut
retrouver un schéma classique de
vaccination mais le problème essentiel
reste le problème des doses et je
n'arrive pas ni avec des chiffres connus
donnés hier où le ministre de donner 3
millions en février 6 millions à mars 6
millions en avril et celle qu'ont donné
vous on n'arrive pas à savoir exactement
quand ils ont été commandés combien ont
été commandés ou pré commander ça paraît
impossible à savoir d'avoir des chiffres
fiables sur les deux que l'on va avoir
et moi ça me paraît le plus à vous même
essentiel parce que c'est lui que je
suis qui justifie l'organisation
logistique qui m'a derrière si on a vu
autant de vaccins qu'on veut on n'a pas
besoin de faire des centres l'accent
coin s'ils étaient de conservation
simple je n'avais que le gouverneur ou
astrazeneca
on pourrait l'organiser très simplement
donc l'essentiel pour moi est très et
serait d'avoir j'allais dire quasiment
semaine par semaine le nombre
deux doses que l'on va recevoir on nous
a parlé en préfecture lundis de 500
mille doses semaine pour mon département
de haute garonne entre 30000 pour hobby
qui compte quatre millions d'habitants
donc soit 30000 deux par semaine quand
est ce qu'il faut on va avoir
suffisamment de doses pour vacciner tous
que l'on devait vacciner
pour moi le problème numéro 1 il est là
c'est le nombre de doses et l'arrivisme
chronologique de ces deux c'est une
question que dans les questions
complémentaires qu'on m'a posée au
ministre et à l'audition d'hier il faut
vraiment qu'on est en effet des chiffres
précis parce que c'est très compliqué de
savoir la réalité entre ce qui était pré
commander commandes et qui va arriver on
avait la même question sur les masques
on le disait ils arrivent ils ont mis ne
soit pas que ce soit
voilà donc toutes les questions ont été
posées professeurs merci donc de
répondre aux dernières interventions
très intéressante sur les durées de
l'immunité tous tout ce qui a été
possible
oui merci beaucoup pour cette dernière
vous de question donc concernant les
publics prioritaires je crois que
c'était là la première question je crois
que vous les avez très très bien lister
les salaires bien sûr il n'y a pas que
les personnes âgées
il y a aussi les personnes ayant des
comorbidités d'ailleurs sur les
personnes âgées je crois que lorsque
vous avez auditionné je vous avais parlé
de cette série danoise de la première
vague plus important surplus dix mille
personnes qui montrait que les risques
étaient commencés à être
particulièrement préoccupant à partir de
l'âge de 50 ans c'est ça les personnes
âgées
c'est à partir de là j'ai 50 ans bien
sûr entre 50 et 70 ans
le risque ressemble à peu près à celui
du strass maladie d'une très grande
gravité
avec à peu près 10 % de mortalité
lorsqu'il ya des comorbidités associées
et sait comment me dit et je ne parle
pas des immunodéprimés ou des
transplantés c'est des pubs des
comorbidités assez banale qui sont
présentes chez à peu près la moitié des
des personnes de ce segment de la
population
et puis au delà de 70 ans ou deux
80 ans enfin ou encore plus au delà de
80 ans avec ou sans comme son co
morbidités vous avez une mortalité qui
avoisine les 50% des pcr positive c'est
à dire qui est absolument effroyable et
donc c'est vrai que c'est bien ce
segment qu'il convient de vacciner avec
ou sans comptabilité mais par ailleurs
ceux qui ont des comorbidités et qui ont
plus de 50 ans devrait être vaccinée
aussi de façon assez urgente
ceux qui ont des très lourd de comment
vous dites et dont vous parlez sont
aussi des gens très prioritaire quel que
soit leur âge alors sur sur le
séquençage
j'aime assez bien la question parce que
c'est exactement l'objectif d'un d'une
épidémiologie moléculaire organiser le
santé publique france la veille
sanitaire classique française doit
prendre en compte de façon extrêmement
systématique un échantillonnage qui peut
être une forme de réseau sentinelles de
l'échantillonnage sur le territoire sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
des souches d'un pourcentage bien
entendu de séquençage de souche
c'est à travers un réseau de ce genre
que l'on pourra détecter des mutations
il y en a tout le temps en permanence
les variants anglais et sud africains
ont entre 17 et 23 mutation c'est ce qui
les rend particulièrement facteur de
préoccupation et d' alerte parce que il
ya quand il ya un grand nombre de
mutations sur un même virus qui
n'oublions pas le génome arn de du
coronavirus est le plus long génome
viral existants des virus à arn tous les
autres virus à arn sont beaucoup plus
courts et donc le fait qu'il y ait des
nombreuses mutations et quelque chose
d'attendu mais c'est un virus qui mute
bout moins que le virus de la grippe est
bien le fait que l'on ait des mutations
est très important à surveiller
notamment parce que pour ce que vous
avez dit pas simplement je crois qu'il
ya aussi la transmissibilité qui est que
l'on étudie est ce que ce nouveau
variant est plus transmissible ça semble
être le cas il va rien anglais et
libériens sud africain que
et aussi la sévérité ou voir même les
formes uniques que engendre ce nouveau
variant est ce qu'elle change pas ça ne
semble pas être le cas de ce nouveau va
rien de ces nouveaux variants et puis
ensuite comme vous l'avez dit très bien
est ce que il ya une forme de résistance
au traitement vaccinale on n'attend pas
trop ce type de nouveaux variants pour
le moment parce qu'il ya pas de pression
de sélection dessus mais si la
vaccination entraîne une pression de
sélection dans la population il se peut
que des nouveaux variants émergent pour
contourner le l'efficacité du vaccin
donc ça c'est à surveiller par le
séquençage sur les deux tours électoraux
versus un mois ou pas j'ai envie presque
de reprendre la la la question qui est
la dernière après qui est un peu lié
adjoindre les médecins généralistes les
infirmiers et les paroissiens
certains ont dit participation du
service de santé des armées
j'ajouterai du don du sang j'ajouterai
les pompiers il ya beaucoup il ya en
france des chiffres que j'ai quitté
l'antenne malheureusement ne sait pas
sous mes yeux mais il y a me semble-t-il
près de 600000 infirmiers infirmières il
me semble qu'il y a près de 250 mille
médecins qui lie à 60000 pharmaciens
encore une fois je
il faudrait vérifier tous ces chiffres
je ne parle pas des étudiants en
médecine
bref il y a un très grand nombre de
personnes je pense que pour maintenir
les votes et les bureaux électoraux dont
on a parlé deux dimanche de suite pas de
suite d'ailleurs mais de séparer de
trois ou de quatre semaines il faudrait
400 mille personnes
donc c'est tout à fait vrai qu'il ya une
très très forte logistique nécessaire et
donc l'idée de réfléchir à cela est
important mais au-delà de cela ce qui
est très important c'est une des choses
dont vous avez dit et vous me permettrez
de passer de leur groupe et cela avec la
dernière question que je reviendrai à la
question du milieu c'est le nombre de
doses dont on dispose c'est exactement
la question et c'est bien sûr vous avez
besoin d'avoir les indicateurs précis
mais au-delà de cela était d'augmenter
la capacité de dos
et vous avez en france l'un des cinq
opérateurs mondiaux du vaccin
le vaccin c'est une industrie
extrêmement difficile qui nécessite un
savoir-faire extrêmement complexe que
vous avez préservé
sur le plan industriel profitez-en c'est
à dire que vous avez quand même la
possibilité avec un industriel très
performant sur le pays d'essayer de
développer une capacité de produire des
doses peut être que par générosité
cette capacité pourrait même être
étendue à d'autres mais dans le fond à
défaut de pouvoir produire un vaccin
made in france
il pourrait produire un vaccin qui vient
d'un autre source avec modern a par
exemple à renonce à tous ses brevets je
sais que ce n'est pas qu'une histoire de
brevet et je sais que sanofi pasteur on
ne peut pas faire du vexin arn messager
ne peut pas le produire il peut
conditionner du bras il peut pas
produire la rn et s'agit au jour
d'aujourd'hui ça se développe pas comme
ça en un tour de main
il faudra des mois et peut-être même
quelques années pour que ce groupe
pharmaceutique soit capable de faire du
vaccin selon cette technologie mais il
est capable de le conditionner et de le
donner aux français
donc je pense qu'il faut réfléchir à
cela parce que qu'importe non pas le
flacon
mais qu'importe la modalité de
dispensation que ce soit dans les
bureaux électoraux de guy vallancien que
ce soit selon les modalités mises en
oeuvre par des médecins généralistes
libéraux des infirmiers ou des
pharmaciens que ce soit à part le
service des armées que ce soit sur un
mois que ce soit sur deux week-ends ce
que l'on voudrait c'est que tout le
monde puisse bénéficier de ce vaccin
voilà donc pour revenir à la question
que j'appelais du milieu l'efficacité à
à 100% durée protection des vaccins
alors la durée de protection des vaccins
au jour d'aujourd'hui
elle est forcément limitée à
l'expérience que l'on en a c'est à dire
depuis les essais cliniques
il faut savoir que c'est une donnée très
très
longues à obtenir la durée de protection
des vaccins aujourd'hui la protection
elle n'est pas remise en question après
plusieurs mois aujourd'hui on a
extrêmement peu de réinfection malgré
les vagues successives
on a donc l'impression que le l'immunité
naturelle en tout cas qu'on faire enfin
le deuil pendant la maladie et confère
une immunité naturelle aux personnes qui
ont été atteintes pendant une période
en tout cas qui dure depuis le début de
la pandémie aujourd'hui on sait aussi
que des gens qui avaient été atteints
par le sar score c'est à dire le strass
en 2003 ont encore des anticorps
neutralisants au jour d'aujourd'hui et
semble toujours protégé contre le strass
peut-être d'ailleurs avec une nuitée
croisés contre des saars coque d'eux
mais ils sont très peu de gens bien
entendu il pourrait être aujourd'hui
encore protégé par par un virus pas par
les anticorps contre un virus qui
ressemble de très près au sart skov 2 du
coup du duc de la copie de 19
donc il est possible que d'immunité même
naturel soit très longue
il est des maladies ou l'immunité
vaccinale est meilleur que l'immunité
naturelle
je sais que mes confrères virologues ils
me disent toujours mais attend on ne dit
pas ça c'est un autre modèle virologique
se suivent la varicelle vaccins à adn
très différents qui n'a qui n'a rien à
voir et qu'il a skié sans dans notre
organisme
toujours est il que quand vous faites
une varicelle dans l'enfance eh bien
vous risquez de faire un zona plus tard
alors que quand vous êtes vacciné contre
la varicelle dans l'enfance ou que vous
êtes vacciné contre le zona qui est le
même vaccin
d'ailleurs c'est exactement le même il a
juste un nom différent et bien vous êtes
protégé contre la varicelle est contre
nous sommes donc il existe des vaccins
qui nous protège mieux que la maladie
parce que la varicelle voudrais te
protège pas contre le zona au contraire
et je dis cela parce qu'il est tout à
fait possible que le vaccin protège
encore mieux contre la copie 19 que
l'immunité naturelle mais ça ça reste
encore à démontrer
rendre le vaccin obligatoire alors au
jour d'aujourd'hui le frein à cela c'est
évidemment qu'il n'y a pas d'essai chez
l'enfant
les essais sont en train d'être mené aux
états unis chez l'enfant donc on aura
peut-être des réponses bientôt
sur la possibilité de donner
d'administrer ce vaccin à l'enfant pour
le moment ce n'est pas le cas et c'est
quand même un des trous dans la raquette
qui existe à propos de ceux de cette
vaccination et qui d'ailleurs empêche
toute stratégie d' immunité collective
comme on en avait parlé au départ donc
pour l'instant il n'y a pas lieu de
rendre un tel vaccin obligatoire
la question qui pourrait se poser un
jour ce serait peut-être moi ça ne me
choquerait pas que le vaccin soit
obligatoire dans les ehpad
parce que vous n'êtes pas obligé d'aller
dans une maison de retraite vous n'êtes
pas obligé d'aller dans une crèche mais
quand vous allez dans une crèche on est
obligé de vacciner parce que c'est pas
votre liberté individuelle ici elle
s'arrête quand même là où commence celle
des autres et la sécurité des autres
résidents d'une maison de retraite ça
pourrait être que tout le monde soit
vaccinée donc je ne serai pas
fondamentalement choqué même si je pense
que tout le monde ne partagera pas mon
avis mais le qu'on puisse dans un
règlement intérieur d'une maison de
retraite demandé que les personnes
soient vaccinés sinon je pense que la
vaccination obligatoire c'est un domaine
politique beaucoup plus que scientifique
et c'est pas tellement à moi de
m'exprimer sur ce sujet davantage voilà
bah écoutez moi pour ma part je sais pas
si j'ai répondu à vos questions mais
comme le dernier intervenant a regretté
de ne pas pouvoir poser des questions
parce que j avais répondu ça va au moins
à conforter sur l'idée que vous aviez eu
quelques réponses à vos questions
non merci beaucoup vraiment de façon
unanime nous sommes ravis de cette cette
audition et surtout de la clarté de la
pédagogie de vos réponses sur des sujets
parfois complexes notamment pour ceux
notre commission qui sont moins moins
férus des termes parfois médicaux mais
merci beaucoup et j'ai peut-être à
bientôt un pour une autre audition en
tout cas merci beaucoup
professeur de de votre intervention ce
matin nous avons consacré consacrer du
temps ce matin danse sur ce sujet majeur
merci beaucoup merci madame la
présidente merci à tous mes amis
[Musique]